こんにちは
こちらスティーブ カウフマンです
今日はね言葉の勉強の目標に
ついて話したいと思います
私のビデオ好きであれば
是非登録してください
鐘のところでクリックすれば
お知らせも届きますから
その言葉を勉強する時に
もちろんその大雑把(おおざっぱ)な
あいまいな目標みんな持ってます
ようは流暢に話ししたいと
しかしこの各段階でですね
目標 私個人の経験であれば具体的な
目標あればまあその継続しやすいんですよ
その目標においてはですね
順番があるんですよ順番
だからその７つの段階の目標について
今日お話したいと思うんですよ
この７つの段階はね
私のイメージではですね
逆さまなピラミッド
みたいなものですよ
だから１番大切な目標はですね
もう語彙言葉言葉
単語覚えないといけない
数の多い実際にはですね
色んなものを理解するために
あるいは話しするためにですね
かなり大きい語彙が
必要なんですよ
だからその単語の数
語彙を増やすのは
私のイメージでは
１番大切な目標
始まる時言葉を
集まらないといけませんし
そしてその続けて
勉強する間でもですね
やはり常に常に
言葉のその単語の数
その収穫ですね
それ続かなければならないんですよ
だからこれ１番
メインの目標なんですよ
その次はですね
その読むこと
すなわち聞くことは
大切ですけれども
私の経験では読めないと
聞いた時は分からないんですよ
だから言葉を覚えて
LingQでも使って
言葉を…
辞書を調べたり
保存したりして
そしてそういう保存した言葉を
少しずつLingQならLingQで読んで
そしてある程度この単語
っていうか語彙を増やした
その上でもう短い文章でも
読む始まることが大事なんですよ
だからそれは第２の目標
LingQではね
その読んだ単語の数
数える訳ですよ
だからそれを
できるだけ増やすこと
できるだけたくさん読むこと
新しいものを読んで
新しい単語を勉強して
それを読むことが
第２の目標なんですよ
第３の目標は
聞くことだから
ある程度当然読むことが
やりやすいわけですよ
時間があるから
知らない単語も調べるし
聞いた時
なかなか明確でない
その単語が読むときは
明確になります
だからある程度
読んだ後にはですね
やはり聞く時間を
増やさないといけないんですよ
聞いた時は分からない
場合もあるから
もう１度読んで
語彙を増やす
だからある程度
全ての目標は
お互いに関係が
あるんですよ
あるけれども
それでも私の
その考え方の中では
順番がある まず単語を
増やすということ
そして読むこと
読む単語の数を増やすこと
それから聞く
聞く理解力を増やすということですね
でそれをやはり
いずれこういう
語彙 読む 聞く
それはインプットと
関係ある訳ですよ
そして第４番目の
４番目の目標はね
それは話すこと
自分のだから
話をすること
だからもちろん
いろんな人がね
大分の人が
第１の目標は
話したいと 会話
話し したいと
だけれども
１ ２ ３の語彙と
読むこと読む能力
読むその理解力
読解って言うんですか
あるいは聞いて分かる
理解力ですね
それがないと
話することが非常に難しい
しかしそのベースがねあれば
あとこの話することが
やりやすくなるんですよ
そして相手の言うことを
理解できるならば
自信が付くわけですよ
だから重要性においては
もしかすると
話すことが１番
大切かもしれないけども
実際にはそれを達成するために
目標の１２３も
達成しないといけません
それはだから４番目
５番目はですね
それはあの正しく
要は文法正しく話したい
そのインプットの
段階ではですね
やはり単語を増やしたり
読んだり聞いたりする時にですね
文法はそれほど
大切じゃないです
まあある程度の
アイデアがあれば
その単語さえあれば
読む聞く能力があれば
文法はそれだけでは
それほど大切じゃないです
しかし話する時にですね
やはりどこが
やはり正確でない
それはネイティブの
ような言い方ではない
それは少しずつ
感じるわけですよ
だからもっと
正しく話したいと
当然意欲が出てくる
その段階ではね
常にある程度
この言葉においては経験がある
たくさん聞いた
たくさん読んだ上で
今度じゃあ文法に
もう少し力を入れることが大事
しかし あくまで５番目
１番目ではないわけですよ
それはやはり文法は語彙
かなりある程度できたと
読む能力もできたと
そしてその聞く
リスニングの能力ができたと
そして話 ある程度
話できるけれども
もう正確ではないと
その段階で今度じゃあ
文法に集中しますというのが
僕は５番目の
目標なんですよ
６番目は書くこと
僕の場合は
やはりフランス語と
その中国語の場合は
書くことが必要で
あったんですよ私の場合は
しかしその他の僕は
大体20カ国語を話せるんだけれども
書かないですよ
書くのはあくまで
あの…あれですよ
コンピューターを
使って書きます
各文章は話するのと
同じなんですよ
わざとその…
ライティングだから
もっと正式に書くって
いうことはあまりしないんですよ
しかし必要があるんですよ
場合によっては
そのライティング
っていうか正しく書く
その場合はやはり
それに集中しないといけません
いずれ私は各目標に関しては別々な
ビデオを作るつもりでありますから
その時にどういう風にして
そのライティングですね
書くことをもっと上手に
正確に説得力の
あるようにするかというのは
また今度ビデオ作ります
だけども重要性としては
少なくとも私の経験では
それほど他の理解力とか
話してることに比べて少ないです
それはもちろんニーズに
必要に応じて
人によっては違います
そして最終的には
僕は文化ですよ 文化
僕はその文化それぞれの言葉の
文化興味ありますよね
そのあるからもうそれこそ
この言葉を勉強してますけれども
できるだけこの言葉で
この文化を知りたいわけですよ
だから英語で僕の場合は
母国語英語ですから
英語で色々こう細かいこと
文化について説明してもですね
僕にその言葉の勉強においては
大切じゃないです
ある程度の水準
できたときに
今度じゃあ色んなその国
その言葉の文化については勉強したい
だからそれは７番目の
やはり目標になります
じゃあそういう意味で
その７つの目標についての
ビデオであった
英語でも同じ
そのシリーズがありますので
是非僕のチャンネルで
その英語でも
ご覧になってください
でこれからも日本語で
１日個別個別に
この各目標について日本語でも
ビデオを作ろうと作りたいと思ってます
じゃあどうもさよなら